after their own all okay tiebreaks I
know we're a few days late me in chess
expand Chris my good friend Chris hi
Chris yeah hi we've been fiddling around
for the last two hours to try and get a
new technology technological
configuration we're going to use the ICC
with multiple examined so Chris can also
control the board as well as me we've
got the game loaded so this was gained
13 so I'll move forward crash ID for by
young girl fans against Alan so 25
minutes each 10 second increments / move
ya Undertown control love to be a yeah
very much an important issue in the
tiebreak yes sir there was a constant
time diff difference between are not
having lots of time and girlfriend
having very little time okay but let's
um get ahead yeah yeah yeahs got the
same opening um um like in the regular
match I think in the regular match we
had the three or four times so a sloth
again yep guard ops for this III move
order um and the the first new move for
the match comes on on the five is closed
in bishop ah ah I'll just whoops i'm
just-just this bishops closed in I'm
just I've never used the dashes
annotation facilities so this is our
having a bit of fun at the same time as
doing this so anyway moving on so II six
is the same love will you call Moran
variation yeah the Moran variation if
black holes night p d700 sorry night
busy seven after night after night yeah
this is a mainline Lorraine variation
aha but in the match we had a six some
you know plate I think three times may
be four times I keep I'm left got job
three or four times what night BTW seven
is new for this match um but of course
not new for games between these players
they both saw
play this align and are not actually um
use this exact opening to be kramnik
twice in the bond match in nineteen no
2008 of course in 2008 so this line
basically won him the match used to
black victories you had different 22
Kramnik who played Bishop d3 here um um
Quincy to write took a fun play Quincy
to Quincy Syria so and then we see
Bishop d6 so black again is that logical
break in the center he's keen on the e5
break so Bishop d free yeah in this in
this position um there's also the the
crazy possibility G form which govern
actually played before it's not like he
is never playing sharp openings but it's
not the kind of line maybe for this tie
break you kind of feel silly if you lose
the first white game so what again I
don't know I think it might be more
appropriate for rapid games to put
pressure on the opponent yeah but it's
also a problem if you bring up exactly
the type of position that you have a
corner dicks Elton so so so Bishop d3
it's just the normal line where white
them can also hope for a bit of pressure
so thoughts now I am both sides castle
and then back play some place a five yes
no no I pressed about oh whoops I need
to get used to this so black played e5
yes and there's some really shows that
he's into yes simplifying the position a
bit on the alternatives here and black
has got a main alternative here this
t-64 gypsy4now black has quite some
choice um I think the main move nowadays
even
it's a 6cm my arm instead of a six you
also have the media b5 and this side
goes on and on theoretically white goes
too III arm omggg e2 and stuff like this
this is some just a different kind of
game lab black keeps or pieces on the
board and this if I've move that that
are non played here we needs to an
immediate opening of the center so go on
to Conde 5 yeah I now played eform and
this opens up the position completely in
the center yeah so here we've got a lot
of central worm tension are on the
central squares ah I turned that off
yeah ok so moving on swiftly so so which
which way is black I'm going to play
here actually he takes on d4 and now we
see knight takes d5 if Knight takes d4
foot we covered that in the game before
night c5 might be good if we just put it
in yet nike air fire that there is this
a good move most likely because I'm not
seeing what why does doing now to
preserve his important Bishop yeah yeah
so um you know okay so what but another
another possibility just just mentioned
briefly let's say it takes takes and now
black could also think about this here
and this is also very decent because of
white moves to the ship now you've got
this this thing going here just win upon
mm-hmm and although thought it might be
move like this but this looks quite
decent for like I think so um it's a
matter of taste maybe yeah so it's not
nothing to be afraid of so why took with
a knight on d5
like we captured and played 86 to cover
h7 porn so very logical um on turn of
events up to now yes and yeah now it's
it's pretty clear that we've got those
some wood weird porn horns here d4 and
d5 the center sort of yeah turned around
usually it would be a white pawn on d4
and a black pawn on d5 and this shows
that yeah this pawns will most likely
get lost in the process and white sir
Amos to somehow emerged with the better
pieces in this completely open position
yeah it's so not not much that you would
get there but it's of course completely
risk-free it looks like but the game
gets complicated later okay so on how
did wipe the seat yeah don't be free now
I guess we should mention if Knight
takes d4 it seems I think bishop age too
is that a good move then you can
recollect that night is that that's why
Knight takes is not particularly good or
is there something even stronger um okay
this yeah this should be fine yeah so
Knight takes d4 is not desirable here as
so be free was played yeah white tries
to win the pawn back with this Bishop
hmm and also this Bishop doesn't have a
good square it could go to d2 but this
would really um don't help at all with
them gaining of the pawn back so um this
just a text defined will help to to
restore materially quality later and
what blacks moves are so quite naturally
I think he played Knight f6 here or okie
aid okay so 9 f six sorry 95 was playing
that you've played okay I'm sorry so
hitting that very valuable bishop so for
prompting White's time to this thing
about that night tanks d free so what
white plays was actually Knight takes e4
live here and after Bishop takes a five
black might have to be careful in some
rations now about f4 to attack that
Bishop but for the moment he plays rook
e1 okay so rookie one and we saw rook e8
and here it's only the Queen protecting
the rook which means that if Queen takes
d5 we'll have f for a new queen is
protecting the rook so I think this is
one of the reasons why an end he plays
now in this position he plays Bishop d7
so all his pieces on the background
connected to each other now there's much
more so this d5 there's no rush to
immediately put pressure on on d5 the
default point also protect anyway yeah
black needs to computer so development
entities also but I slob see Aiden move
with tempo on the Queen yeah so finish
developing first hmm so now Queen d2
pre-empting rook c8 and maybe f4 might
be interesting in some variations it
looks otherwise weakening you won't
normally want to play that but I Queen
d2 gets out the way anyway I've roots
the eighth and so we see Queen f6 which
which looks quite logical putting more
support for d4 as well as more pressure
on f4 square yeah and also you've got
this Bishop f4 North if yes why Dwight
would play like something like Roxy one
then we should therefore would be good
yeah we should have four words put that
back maybe I should find out what those
come-ons do before doing this stuff all
right let's swiftly move on it looks
funny so G free was played um gee free
yeah I think this uh have both the idea
of maybe going F for after all at some
point you need to be cautious with this
move but a form and also this Bishop a
form was quite annoying possibility
because you know don't all you also
don't have a good square for the Queen
really so you know this makes sense so
now Roxy ADA Thank You Brooke CITS just
quit neither there is a bit of a
compromise here on on the light squares
here these lights flare a bit weekend
aren't they with g3 yeah it's a not a
move that you route should make with
without considering this you know looks
nice ok so ops ii eight and this
discolor complex also um can't gets
important he immediately now governed I
think when a for right yes I fool so
what is the intention of i-4 yeah yeah I
think it was ya think swidler in the
comentary sort of it's a little bit of a
passing move like okay I'll do a little
bit of strengthening here and you show
me what what what your plan is um I
think your party is he's right but it
also has some some little ideas one idea
could be something like Bishop to c4
securing this see 4.4 for the dish it
and maybe at some point they might also
be Bishop b5 as an idea it just what I'm
thinking of immediately otherwise this
move is not doing much besides weakening
III and this is an immediate problem you
know because I sir Anand now enter
queena three and this sent girlfriend
into a deep thought because what are you
doing now yeah the problem problem is
that you somehow need the situation
there for one move potentially to cover
the GG to square
oh yes let go shebesh 3 and 73 is just
hanging yes so this is quite annoying
here Oh blimey yes so Bishop b4 he's
hanging be free hair so in this position
if if black is allowed Bishop h free and
forces bishop f1 then so if well it's
not black smoke but say this then Bishop
H free Bishop f1 well you could take him
then just take on be free so this yeah
so Bishop efore kicks that Queen if we
were back to the main line kicks that
Quinn yeah he tries to avoid this kind
of this kind of line and tries to stay
active here but he's sacrificing be free
yeah this wasn't wasn't intended when
you played a form you know you could you
could really spot that he overlooked
Weiner three are not the move itself but
the consequences he maybe didn't assess
karate so yeah I don't know grabbed on
b3 and his opponent the only issue being
that black screen has exactly one square
available Queen B 6 so this is a bit of
a dramatic point in the game already
that son and then the current world
champion you know he's won a pawn he is
notorious for being one of the best
rapper players so this is a dangerous
situation so can white generate
compensation and blacks also know he's
not is he threatening anything apart
from that he's just it's just tricky one
opponent the Queen bit gets back to
safety it's going to be really bad so
this next move exposes a potential
discovered attack where Bishop takes d4
on that Queen yeah I think black wasn't
threatening anything in particular mmm
yeah maybe here Queen B 6 sent back with
her just keeping the porn but this recur
to be one immediately um yeah sharpens a
sharpened disposition immensely because
no white yeah
intends to get the default back and is
close to also catching the Queen so it
gets very tactical now and I think
didn't we should take on g3 now so in
this position Bishop takes g3 yes
exposing an attack on this bishop rook
takes e4 if this is routinely captured
rook takes e4 that would be unpleasant
so this is a very dramatic position now
after Bishop takes g3 so white has a few
choices can I get rid of this heroine oh
ok let's just see what white plays here
Brooke a free in the position so he's
got his Bishop hanging on e4 but blacks
bishops is ready to be taken on G free
but in this position ok so black hair
with his Queen attacked plays Queen B 6
yeah it's quite a funny position yeah
God kinds of stuff is hanging g3 is
hanging and he fought so yeah and we cut
a little bit of a technical sequence now
I think it took on d4 now IAM right so
taking on d4 with the bishop protecting
that rook so the queen is double
attacked and if it just moves then maybe
rook takes g3 is really dangerous
coordinating an attack on g7 here which
yeah i think if you yeah if you compared
to the compared to the game in which a
nunchuck on h2 yes i think it it can
lead to a very similar position it's
just that black ass want a movie and
also porn in the process so why it took
now which i think is so sensible yeah
and now I'm I can give this this check
again you need to remove the Queen after
all from this double attack yes
and then it's really yeah we have a
scary position with this coordination
now on g7 so this is arguably one of the
more exciting games already of the match
in this run yeah definitely never did
quite quite dramatic so okay black needs
to get this piece bag of course and g7
it was quite frightening here with g7 he
plays Bishop takes g7 so threatening to
win the Queen if nothing else with
Bishop g5 check okay yeah it's of course
a very complicated position but like in
I think all games I don't you had a huge
time time advantage so this is very
important to to see um because this sort
of influence the game now a lot i think
so i think what did you play king age 7
yeah if i remembers yeah like chicken
skin 87 which protects h6 as well and
maybe Brooke GA is now very useful rook
h4 is also a potential useful move so
yeah it's a very very understandable
move especially with low time but but
white can't take on g7 now funny enough
there be seven sorry not cheesy so enjoy
peaceable yeah you can take on I think
you did yeah we took on b7 oh yes it
will be something yeah and now it gets
quite interesting so this position is
arguably even good for white now um with
this setup that we that we have no I
also have the possibility to to start up
an engine here and do a little bit of a
computer analysis on the side if it gets
too complicated and I just decided that
I should switch it on we can also didn't
have time to prepare really for file for
the game okay maybe you should buy I
shouldn't we'll just uh yeah just just
once in a while
get it set itself for once in a while if
it gets really complicated to to have a
look but you shouldn't let the the
engine do the thinking all the time it
doesn't help but once in a while it's
good to to double check what you're
seeing yourself so um I don't remember
what where she played here the check on
edge show launched at the next move it
was rook g8 and his passion she hm okay
so route g8 was played here attacking
that Bishop it seems is that bishop
needs to move it seems um but okay yeah
and here here you were just very
important here girlfriend was very down
on time i'm not i'm not sure exactly how
many seconds or whatever he had left but
if you would have more time here i'm
pretty sure it would find the right move
for just 23 quit if it looks like a
dangerous move with the non sleep in
couldn't get free yes North epen against
that rook so what would black do here
against this pin yeah it's fairly
complicated black hood of course I'm
play something like f5 like protecting
this with a pawn but this is very
dangerous some a move like this should
be two is quite dangerous here we should
be too what about your free looks quite
I denies that too dangerous for play F
is a losing move for why every I'm not
sure um I'm not sure what you doin
either i'm not i'm not using the compy
on f3 just rocky seven maybe it's the
sir what what do i do what do you do now
all right okay so yeah i'm not sure but
I Bishop b2 is very strong because um it
it just be passing fly Quincy 30 yes and
it means that Bishop now yeah he pins
the b7 Bishop and it's really hard
should like to to do anything he has a
very cool knight in attack on g7 this is
sort of a crossfire now off of both
ropes and yeah that is
tied up in Miss Lee no I think it's very
critical for black right so this Queen D
free yes and if Bishop f5 was played
here is that losing immediately to rook
takes f7 yeah you can't take on f7 what
about the check rook age for check check
it gets very complicated because there's
Bishop b5 after all this we win the
Queen yeah the thing is you need to
calculate orders here this is checkmate
mr. 85 oh my word yeah the tactics and
the backfires yeah this is checkmate so
it wasn't do Christmas Queen d3 wasn't
an easy move fair no no it wasn't it's
brilliant like okay you do this and it's
easy but you need to see all this set on
queen d three british / 5 rook f7
actually is working and i'm not sure
maybe he was already done on 2nd he was
very low on time this is this I remember
um for sure but not quite sure how low
it was and the thing is if you play
Queen h6 here which you did this is just
a position you cannot lose this wide so
ah but it's the golden opportunity to be
up I mean in this you know he's worked
some of the years to get to this point
hasn't he for all the qualifiers he he
bit Grizz truck who'd one of the top
Russian grand masti come to all this
plot you hold and end in the main match
and these critical it's such painful
thing away these blitz games these rapid
games yeah a rapper deserve it small
matter of nerves and also offer engine
would use would be signed this this
player very clearly of using your time
properly and it's no doubt about it i
think by now everyone's no no so result
is so we don't do any spoiling here so
I'm Jeff on the losses match but if you
look at the games he was clearly the the
player we should have won it hmm just
from if you look at the ad missed
opportunities you could have won this
match pretty easily so go zoom on here
week windy free happen
it's just the thing is it doesn't help
if you only have 10 20 seconds on the
clock so but it seems it seems almost
accidental that he drops be free but it
gave him this huge look later on the
seventh round was exerting influence
that's crazy it's very random it's very
random and I was also quite quite
surprised how quickly this quiet type of
maneuvering game turned into this yes
crazy position so just to wrap it up
after Queen age 6 we have a mass
exchange here and then and there's just
nothing left yeah oh my word for this
route Bishop versus rogue Bishop c8
bishop CA does an important move him and
just it's important if if black would
capture immediately on age 6 he would
need to defend something rook endgame
with with corn down because no a7 is
actually hangings yeah white would have
any extra porn and gypsy aid is just
just a better move which um avoids all
kinds of unpleasant stuff no because now
White has no choice he needs to attack
the bishop himself they whoop c7 or
rupee 8 i'm not sure losses have nothing
to the roots and kicked off that seven
Frank avoid so it's not automatic double
tap attacking these two poems yeah so
now King takes rook takes on c8 and rook
takes a four yeah it is just dead so
black doesn't have earned a place that
leg isn't a born down simply and can
easily stop the deep on with this King
Andrew combined so it's just just a dead
position so yes this was was a big
opportunity coming up sort of out of the
blue for our girlfriend with the
squeegee three move before actually it
was equal but it isn't easy to play of
course so on and can you blame mounted
in debt that he got into this into this
position it's very was very complicated
and he also said in the press conference
if he we were quickly back to this this
position rook takes b7 and I'm he said
in the press conference that he had seen
this this move but he couldn't believe
it would work so yeah he thought of
relied upon this move not working and
now black is already in some trouble our
thing especially an in rapid you don't
have ed they didn't have the possibility
to think for 10 minutes at some point
this would have certainly helped in this
position so I kind of a missed
opportunity em let's do a quick overview
in summary so we see a repeat of the
Slav from the main match but with night
bd7 in sort of a 6 which Anand is very
experienced with but now we saw Queen c2
instead of Kramnik type Bishop d3 and
then black breaking in the center
quickly with e 5 i'm just saying do you
I don't see the body at the moment I'd
season mod with rook checks b7 oh sorry
sorry sorry I'll go back on the
mind-control sorry sorry do you see the
board now yeah yeah I do oh no they gave
in your honor I used the wrong
controller buttons follow me okay so
sorry just to recap so we saw repeat the
Slav with Quincy to now black breaking
in the center with this quick 'if I've
and II for mass tension in the center
and of the night takes d5 a pileup on
the default bit reminiscent of a one of
the match games where there's everything
on the D file but here we saw now be
free earth Knight d4 there might be none
Bishop takes h2 and then Queen h4 so
actually
five now which makes the bishop is
automatic protecting d4 and that
protection is now increased soon with
Queen f6 I here protecting the bishop
protecting deform or so both porns in
the opposing territory are not subject
to immediate capture for a while instead
we see ok g3 which looks a bit
controversial weakening these squares
around the king but now 84 which looks
even more perhaps controversial in the
light of blacks next move which not only
attacks crudely these weaknesses created
by G through of crude threats like
Bishop a tree but they're effective
because if the bishop move back then
Queen takes be free seemingly just clear
porn up but in the game a black seemed
to go ok almost a clear porn up anyway
after Bishop b4 Bishop more aggressive
on e4 rather than f1 though so this is
now a gambit situation so what does
black got sorry what has white dot for
this gambit it'd be free porn there's a
lot of chasing that can be done though
against this Queen very hard to tell if
you if you look at it now um we had to
tell what was black doing wrong here
because he sort of got into trouble but
you would think he's a clear point up I
thought this as well so maybe I'm not
quite sure what he did wrong they're
young yeah hard hard to tell really hard
to tell it looked looked very um cam
very logical in a way maybe a safe move
his Queen B 6 because Bishop d4 you got
Queen D for but instead he plays Bishop
g-free here may be Queen B 6 might be an
alternative that's what was played so
Bishop d3 really answers even more
complications doesn't it yeah this is
really the kind of show me move because
because actually there is this fret of
rook hey for as well so Bishop g3 is
going into this Queen b6 and I wonder
you know why can't the Queen return back
to f6
I do not use any major thing for white
here yeah thank you to be my idea would
be Bishop e3 here p 7 is an issue ah so
just was just an idea yeah but yeah it's
very complicated let's say Queen f6 yeah
and they've white would take now then d3
is a pretty nasty move the rook moves
Roxy too Oh blimey hahahahaha Oh blimey
that is bad stuff very very tactical I
am and very inconvenient um yeah
complicated stuff yeah maybe queen bee
six maybe could be six was was a good
idea but also Bishop a threesome maybe
but was just the first idea that I had
um maybe this is better possible hmm the
Queen looks safe home I think he Jay
maybe you just wanted more I'm heat is e
so this tactic will get him a second
poem potentially potentially but rookie
free and yeah it's it's getting to be a
really hairy position now so his Queens
double attacked check it's possible that
he that he came up if you look at this
line it's very forced yeah bishop edge
to King edge to hmm Queen d6 check rook
to e3 is all pretty much logical and
maybe when he played this he sawed off
from underestimated something here like
Bishop g7 King g8 and then he may be
rugby seven he didn't you didn't
consider rupee seven maybe and just
thought okay I'm threatening Luke g8
you're expelling this bishop and you
black it also has got some ideas like
row gauge for check and stuff like this
so maybe he just didn't didn't see this
move in once you're into this line you
cannot really divert anymore you have to
play the same possible always have to
remember they need to take this
decisions
seconds yeah he's not the tournament
game yeah and the thing is I think what
what's what's anand pick edwarde she his
he's able to make those moves pretty
quickly and they're not usually they're
not so bad that they that they would
lose the game if he if he makes a
mistake yeah that this mistakes are
rather rather smallish so they wouldn't
lose the game immediately but this this
was one a girlfriend really could have
taken taken advantage of this but I
think he was just too low on time yeah
22 really calculate this properly and
then decided to you know to play this
cop out move Queen takes a exactly my
thinking bailout move Bishop takes
actually is it Queen takes a chicken's
of bile our simplification I don't
usually black has that painful Bishop c8
so there's no advantage whatsoever yeah
I think it would have been a draw anyway
but this is just just completely dead
and um yeah it was very really an
exciting game yes yeah at times I know
there are times when I just think of a
km will sir classical tournament games
are pretty nice but is intrepid just
more fun to watch it's very very often
the case i'm biased you know my rapid my
ECF rapid is puts me in the top 60 i
think with tone i might be going up I
really like rapid but it's not with
increments so this is more casual rapid
with the 10 second increment yeah but
the thing is worth with the increment I
think it's to me it's it's very I don't
understand actually at all why online
even why there is some white people play
without increment because it's just a
much more close to crop a chess than so
I would immediately ditch those five
million auto pairings for instance four
three two auto pairing immediately then
I will just stop playing 550 immediately
and I also prefer one plus one bulk
bullet but
I think something's will like the
increasing time pressure elements yeah
of course it's understandable it's
thrilling of course me but I very much
appreciate to have a little bit of an
increment so that I can actually win
with the Queen up or can draw with rook
versus rook which some people play on
time it just it just prevents people
from being total idiots yeah to be to be
honest but ok this very much diverse
from the game now i think is great too
great a morality on the chess board with
the increment you know yeah it's it's
just I think it's just sometimes if it's
very clear from from the position point
of view that there's no way to progress
and so on it just makes more sense to
2-2 draw the to draw the game and to be
able to to ditch out the simple move
that you can can really get your half
point or whatever yeah and I think it's
also good that they use increment in all
those Tiger tiebreak games besides the
this notorious armageddon game at the
end which which we didn't get to it
could have easily gotten into blitz
games of course because the elephant had
more than enough chances to play at
least two to time but you know ok ok
this was Game one ok we'll upload this
and see if you guys like it on you sure
hope we hope you got something from it
ok thanks Chris ok we'll try this and
see how it goes and then maybe do some
other games later yeah sure ok thanks
very much yeah thanks bye